♪ ♪ ♪
- La question, c'est sur quoi
tu veux qu'on "focusse"
aujourd'hu
- Malgré un suivi médical serré,
Geneviève Marcotte continue
d'avoir de sérieux symptômes
de la COVID, 13 mois après avoir
contctcté la maladie.
GENEVIÈVE MARCOTTE
- Je suis allée seulement
deux heures dans les magasins.
J'étais accompagnée, il y a
ququelqu'un qui me poussait en
chaise roulante, puis suite à ça
j'ai pris presque une semaine
à m'en remettre.
- Jadis très active, Geneviève
a dû retourner vivre chez
ses parents, à 36 ans.
Pour l'instant, il est
impensable qu'elle reprenne
son travail de directrice
des missions commerciales
à l'Université Laval.
- Je dirais que ma batterie est
peut-être à 10 %. Si j'arrive
à 12 %, si je dépense 12 %
d'énergie, je fais un malaise
post-effort et c'est là en fait
que tous mes symptômes
réapparaissent, mais de façon
vraiment exagérée. Je vais avoir
des douleurs musculaires,
la peau qui vient avec une
sensation de brûlure, des gros
maux de tête, un épuisement
qui me laisse alitée.
- Des gens comme Geneviève,
il en passe beaucoup dans
le bureau de son ergothérapeute.
L'approche habituelle de
réadaptation, qui implique
parfois de repousser les limites
du patient, ne fonctionne
simplement pas.
CAROLINE THÉBERGE,
ergothérapeute, ntnté Réadapt.
- Avec la COVID longue, c'est
comme l'inverse qui se produit.
Dès que les gens poussent un peu
trop leurs limites, ils "re-
crashent",lsls retombent, ils
empirent leurs symptômes. Ça
fait que les gens ils vivent
vraiment de l'incompréhension,
beaucoup de détresse, du stress.
- L'plpleur du problème est
difficile à quantifier.
La CNESST, qui couvre les gens
ayant contracté la COVID
sur les lieux du travail,
verse actuellement des
indemnités depuis plus de 6 mois
à0101 personnes, au Québec.
Mais toutes les celles qui,
comme Geneviève, ont attrapé
la maladie ailleurs
qu'au travail, et sont couvertes
par des assureurs privés,
sont invisibles dans
les statistiques.
SIMON DÉCARY, professeur,
École de réadaptation,
Université de Sherbrooke
- Est-ce que je crois qu'il y a
des milliers de personnes qui
ne sont pas retournées à leur
pleine capacité de travail avant
l'infection? Oui, ça, je suis
assez certain.
- Le chercheur Simon Décary,
spécialiste en réadaptation,
croit qu'on a socialement
sous-estimé les effets de
la COVID sur le marché
du travail. Il en appelle
à la compréhension
des assureurs.
- Et c'est pas terminén n fait,
là... Parce que là on a
les données scientifiques
qui démontrent qu'on peut avoir
un cas de COVID longue à trois
mois par-dessuunune triple
vaccination, puis une infection
à l'Omicron.
- J'ai appris que la meilleure
façon, c'est vraiment de
me couch.....
- Un jour à la fois, Geneviève
apprend gérer son nouveau
quotidien. Mais devant le temps
- J'ai appriquque la meilleure
façon, c'est vraiment de
me coucher...
- Un jour à la fois, Geneviève
apprend gérer son nouveau
quotidn.n. Mais devant le temps
qui s'étire, les questions
fusent, et les réponses manquent
encore.
- Quand je vais arriver au bout
dede toutes ces ressources-là,
puid que je ne serai pas encore
capable de travailler, qu'est-ce
qui va se passer? Est-ce que
je vais avoir du soutien?
- Ici Alexandre Duva